bienvenue dans le making-of de dessiner
un alien
je déclare ouvert le tournage de ce film
dessine moi un alien c'est un sketch sur
meeke qui obligé de donner un cours
d'arts plastiques a désormais bien sûr
ça se passe mal se passe très mal quoi
parce qu'il veut pas donner un cours et
aussi parce qu'un alien qui débarque
qui dit ce qui est un peu farfelu guy
ludovic forcément j'ai obligé lui
demander de réaliser le sketch prix est
venu me voir il avait déjà écrit son
sénat il m'a dit ah ouais je n'ai pas un
réal aux biens pour faire ça je veux
donner ce qu'ils en face de toi et puis
si les beaux soirs vous rigolez il est
super fort pour faire des situations
hyper saugrenue il arrive à essayer de
me faire jouer différemment créer un
vrai personnage raconte j'ai toujours
d'une manière un peu de jouer les
personnages de tous il avait baissé de
deux cas c'est ça à trouver autre chose
et ça démarre doucement s'il va faire le
courant d'une question de passer et la
pam un vaisseau pam and aliens il est à
un enfant une porte et un concierge qui
disparaissent sur 10 ans tout ça plus
marrant si sont transformés en kaka vers
le fait qu'elle est en gros branleurs
qui fait rien de sa vie et qui est forcé
par sa mère a donné un cours de dessin
parce que il a il a pris des cours de
dessin sans qu'il ait jamais les encours
s'éduquer que je fais parce que je
ressemble à un rasta blanc et là on va
faire un petit bout mais juste le pouce
le bas ni bien dans ce personnage
je trouve que le blond il va très bien
et finalement cette aventure va le faire
collaborer avec des enfants eva qui fait
finalement le partage
je n'ai pas eue avec sa pièce un peu
d'argent et une écoute un des enfants
rigoler je suis pas content de tourner
avec les enfants ils sont vraiment
adorables
ils sont tous un peu comédien je trouve
mon crew ou car on est tous avec mega
sur voila je l'équipe de bouffer tout on
a fait mille trucs ensemble on a parlé
des voitures
on a la petite julian par exemple qui a
joué dans pas mal de filles notamment
dans le film de dany boon lock est
vraiment adorable par le dessin fait
qu'il ait pas d'effets spéciaux c'est
impressionnant mais qui va t-on à lierre
et jouets des enfants donc voilà j'ai
dit ouais ça fait très projet hybride
fut trop chaud c'est trop motivé par le
projet et du coup et moi je me concentre
vraiment sur tout le visuel ci il est
vraiment en tant que comédien sur le
projet il me fait confiance je suis un
peu notre bébé à 2 il ya un plan aux
drones tournée juste au dessus de
l'école comme ça qui va suivre des
enfants qui courent un plan qui est très
cher à ludovic parce que les que ça
s'inspire un peu de shining dire mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut m'appeler sané
kubrick ou lui brille il ya une astuce
très intéressante c'est que la porte
n'est pas du tout une porte extérieure
alors là il n'y a pas de neige et de ria
la neige est aussi du fonds vert pour
ajouter des tailleurs comment faire
naître la peur là dedans on voit déjà tu
filmes à madeleine flippant tu crées des
cadres ont fait des contre plongées ont
les arrivées très lente des contre-jours
du père menaçant n'arrive pas trop à
savoir ce que c'est et ensuite car notre
en gagnant super important que faire la
peur s'est tu filmes des gens qui ont
peur
alors donc on est un peu dans une
ambiance impôts est ce parce que sont
les un peu dans des lumières un peu
surréaliste voilà je rigole c est
nantais jamais bien filmé rire c'est
énorme mais il pense que la jeune équipe
ultra stylé mais alors pas dû souvent
quatre ou cinq grosses marionnettes il
ya eu plusieurs étapes pour la
construction une partie qui a été fait
par des costumiers donc on avait le
costume qui étaient réalisés en annexe
on a réalisé la construction du corps à
l'intérieur de la lienne n'a encore port
est un mécanisme avec des servomoteurs
et damien l'intérieur le comédien
pouvait contrôler le coût et une partie
voilà des mouvements de la bière elle
est plein de petites manette pencher la
tête l'aller qui tirent les neuf juges
ne sait pas où il va exactement quand on
lui a mis des traces au sol et du coup
avec ses genoux il voyait plus de mots
et de vod
on peut dire ça y est c'est vraiment
petite industrie à lui tout seul toit et
concernant le pistolet on a fait la
réalisation sur un logiciel de 3d il a
été imprimé ensuite en 3d avec moi là
bien parce que je suis en train de
régler plan oui on a eu une super équipe
pour créer les effets spéciaux ce
c'était super important notamment pour
le vaisseau spatial l'oeil de la lienne
la dispersion de la porte du gardien et
de la petite léa alors je vais prendre
en photo loïc tanson agréé pour pouvoir
venir de scanner en 3d l'utiliser pour
les effets où il souhaite faire en 3d
ils vont faire un effet spécial des
petits oignons
parce que les effets spéciaux on sera
deux sur le projet tout ça sera
remplacée en place pendant pourra
retirer ces deux mots clés revers la
veille avec des réflexions de la salle
et ça défonce un les effets sont super
réaliste grande huile est vraiment
flippant enfin ça fonctionne carrément
on est super content l'idée voilà
c'était un peu concurrencés spielberg
maintenant on arrive dans le game tout
le monde a peur on est en train
d'organiser la petite avant-première
pour quelques privilégiés
petit avant première mais danser aussi
dans les nouveaux nouveau studio donc on
essaie là où on tourne avec squeeze
toutes les vidéos gaming et où on va
regarder le court métrage sur le nouveau
recul est de samsung qui est partenaire
j'espère que ça va plaire aux gens ça va
envoyer du lourd que j'espère ok ok
l'élan problèmes qu'on organise un bien
énorme problème
en fait vous voyez les rushes du
tournage je vous explique et je me suis
fait un jus d'orange je vais tomber jus
d'orange dessus il est tombé à la
toilette j'ai tué non c'était une blague
parce que c'est une femme temps là la
rencontre sur la lienne et gaëtan danse
de fin de tournage
waouh
[Applaudissements]
aller où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]